hello everyone and welcome to game
number two of the 2018 World Chess
Championship between Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiano Caruana after a really
exhausting Game one where Coulson had a
lot of chances well it's hard to say if
he had a lot of chances they were
winning but just because the
supercomputer says it swing that doesn't
mean that anyone should expect a human
to actually win that game but okay you
know it's if you ask you know a lot of
different people they will tell you a
lot of different stuff like should he
have won that game or not but regardless
I was very interested to see how Coulson
will approach Game two
what's the white pieces after having
such an exhausting game I don't know
it's hard to say who was more exhausted
by Game one cousin who was basically
torturing Khurana would the white pieces
after the first four hours
up until the seventh hour of the game or
Caruana who was defending it the
position but still this game will
feature a very nice position already
unmoved in that most likely pretty much
every Grandmaster in the world thought
about a certain move that was unplayable
but then Caruana showed otherwise and
you will see that in this game also it's
I will also mention this but at some
point during the game I would like to
also share a couple of nice photos with
you all of the photos are again
compliments by Nicky Riga so be sure to
check out her other work which there
will be a link to her social media in
the description below here we have a
very nice photo of Carlson writing down
well I don't know if he's actually
supposed to write down his name I kind
of I'd kind of guess they would prepare
this for him but I think they actually
do write down everything even the name
which seems kind of redundant but you
know better to keep at least some
tradition so there you have it all so
here is a very nice photo of course and
drinking that that water that is always
present in every chess tournament I
actually tried it it's it's actually
quite nice has has a bit of a bit of an
aftertaste but you know if you like it's
something like a hardened taste but it's
very very different I never
right anything like it really here we
have a very nice photo Fabiano rocking
that st. Louis chess club suit actually
saw Rex Sinquefield he was you know
mingling with with other people in the
audience having a chat with with a lot
of individuals also giving some
interviews and he was actually one of
the few people there that were really
concentrated for help for the entire
game from from the start to the end of
the game and also here we have a very
nice shot of the audience in the in the
playing hall also one of the things I
wanted to mention is that for those of
you who were able to come and check out
the games either game one or two what
are your what are your impressions of
you know the entire venue the players
area the the place for the spectators to
the play a place for for the media for
the press
what are your water really what is your
opinion of the entire event the
organization be everything the the price
of being able to participate in such an
event really really interested in in
your opinion and amber glad to have met
some of you who were able to come and
say hi to me and I I really tried to go
around as much as possible to meet as
many of you take as many photos as
possible so I'm very glad that a lot of
you who were able to make us really made
this entire event even more special for
me and also the there's a there is one
person that I was extremely excited to
meet yesterday I had the privilege of
meeting them zombies from deep mind and
he's really a remarkable individual at
some points of the conversation I really
felt like a chimp even talking to him
because he's saying his smart would be
would really be a huge understatement
but even though I'm sworn to secrecy
about what was discussed at the sitting
with him and some other very very cool
individuals you know very you know it's
definitely a good good time to be alive
and great things are coming
so that being said let's check out this
very nice game his game to Carlson has
the white pieces and he opens the game
with none other than d4 okay with Knight
to f6 Knight to f3 the 5 c4 and by now
you already know what we are transposing
into of course it is the Queens gambit
declined it's a 6 Knight to c3 Bishop to
e7 Bishop to f4
with castles this was all played pretty
much instantly and it will be of every
opening will be played to a certain
degree instantaneously because one one
interesting aspect of this World Chess
Championship is that the photographers
there will be like first 30
photographers that arrived at the venue
will be allowed in there to take photos
of course and in Caruana but only for 10
minutes that that is an agreement
reached between both Magnus and Fabiano
so only only only 10 minutes for these
30 individuals that have a right to take
photos and then the official
photographers are allowed to take photos
for another half an hour Nikki being one
of them so okay
yeah we have III C 5 and here D captures
on c5 and okay this is still the
standard theory of the Queens gambit
declined bushel captures on c5 Queen to
c2 Knight to c6 we have a three Queen 25
and now comes looked d1 and this is move
10 and this is the position that we've
discussed so much now well not we here
but it is position that was played
plenty of times by plenty of
grandmasters through different times in
history and here well the the most
common move was Bishop to e7 by black
and Carlson was very much prepared for
everything
up until this point but here Khurana
played a move that I've already
mentioned pretty much everyone in the
world thought was unplayable here
Khurana played rook to d8 and Ivan saw
tweet my Nigel short he said that his
entire life he thought that roof to d8
was unplayable because of night 2d - and
I've checkup
I've checked up on a lot of games in the
database work 2d 8 was played by weaker
players and then Knight the d2 was in
fact used to either win the game for
white or you know maybe draw the game
for white but looked at the 18 never
actually brought anything for black and
one of the reasons is let's say now if
black decided to play D captures on c4
you would get Knight captures and after
for example black exchanges rooks you
would get Queen d8 offering an exchange
and after Queen captures captures white
would start developing and you can see
that white has a some lead in
development and black really has nothing
to show for here oh it's hard to say if
this would in be in any way enough for
white to put for anything but most
likely not
but you don't want a position like this
with the black pieces right from the
start but it's even more impressive what
happens if black doesn't capture on c4
what if black pushes d4 and this is
something that most likely Carson spent
a lot of time calculating and before I
talk about this variation a bit more the
first thing you will see in the
description below is actually a tweet by
mr. Olympia where he said Magnus Carlsen
intense stare after Fabiano score one at
10 root d8 threatened to melted the
glass panel between the players and the
spectators
so before continuing to watch my video
do check it out hey you will see it's a
nice gift now of Magnus staring at
Fabiana after Fabiano played rook to the
8th it's really really a special and
cool moment so do check it out it will
take you like ten seconds and then come
back and continue watching this so say
why perhaps Carlson was calculating this
d4 idea is because it leads to an
extremely cool variation Knight to b3
attacking both the Queen and the bishop
here the Queen on a5 and the Bishop on
c5 and now after Queen to b6 as the
Queen does have to defend it the Bishop
on c5 you can't go anywhere else and
it's also interesting even if the bishop
was not attacked rooted eh takes away
the dates the Queen's retreat Square so
after the Queen moves and now comes
Knight to a4 with an attack on the Queen
and also a double attack
both of the Knights are attacking the
bishop on c5 he would get Bishop to b4
check most likely karana most likely had
even this prepared pawn captures Queen
captures with check now the queen is
also attacking the knight and now if you
move the King you you heard you're not
really doing anything you're black and
simply either capture the knight d3
would perhaps be an idea sometimes in
the future and if you don't move the
King you can block with the knight 92
and now nothing nothing really happens
here but one of her one of other
interesting things is that if something
like this is played then Queen eight
five white will keep the extra piece but
now you are taking away the g5 Square
from White's bishop also you're
preparing a five and here white wouldn't
really have all that much to do here and
Carlson had to calculate all of this to
decide whether it was even possible to
capture the piece because now pretty
much whatever you do black will punish
you if you try something like Bishop to
e2 you'll get d3 and of course now your
Queen and Bishop is under attack black
would be winning here if you try
something like Bishop to d3 it's no
better because e 5 now attacking the
bishop bishop to g3 and now nice to be
for your queen and Bishop is under
attack you move the Queen and now pawn
captures on e3 and the white is falling
apart there is now a double attack
opened on your Bishop on d3 we have the
rook and the night and I mean there's
again nothing to do here you can capture
white will capture black will capture
with check King moves and now you will
even move the knight on a 4 so this
would be very unfortunate for white and
again there's there's very little you
can do you can't it's very hard to
improve on this position if you play
something like Bishop to g3 again not
much is happening black will simply
start capturing he will open up the
entire the entire center and of course
capturing like this will result in
Knight captures the entire Center is now
open up the Queen is under attack you
have to move the Queen tonight is also
taking away the B 3 square from the
White Queen you would have to move the
Queen now comes Queen captures on a four
and again a very unpleasant position for
white
so after this rook to d8 move by karana
Carlsen really had a lot to consider
here and he did this is the first move
were either player spent some time cost
and spent 16 minutes on his next move
and he decided to avoid all known
possible theory with this nice study -
that was considered to be the way to go
for white if black plays roof to d8 and
played Bishop to e2 and okay Caruana
immediately replied Knight to e4 a very
nice central square for the knight also
comes with an attack on Knight to c3
which is a paint piece as you can see
again Carson took some 12 minutes here
and he decided to castle also the King
now on pinned and here you can see the
power of preparation Carson had to spend
half an hour for his 10th and 11th move
so Knight captures on c3 Bobby decides
to exchange here B captures on c3 and
now comes H 6 H 6 it was a really cool
move as when I when I arrived yesterday
I was I was greeted by a person a
developer from Lille hs0
for for Kurt we Singha and he said hey
man are you are good matter I said yeah
man and he introduced himself to me
saying that he is one of the developers
of Lee Lash's zero and I asked how will
you be like following the game with
Leela and he said yeah you know you can
join me if you want to and of course I
joined him very happily and it was right
about disposition we were he was
explaining to me the interface of Leo
how ela works and and and such and Leela
was giving some seven alternative lines
here and one one of the top lines Leela
was offering was h6 saying that it is it
is by far the strongest idea here and I
asked him ok is this like really now
this is the strongest idea I as I don't
know if it was the top idea was the
strongest or the bottom it's not really
a graphical interface it's on mostly
numbers and he said they're like yeah
but humans never play the top
recommendation by Leela and it's very
interesting here carvanha actually did
play h6
and the move Lila considered to be the
strongest of course there's nothing to
be gained by capturing this point it is
impossible rook to a-1 would trap the
Queen and the bishop captures on a3 also
we don't want to allow rook to e1 I mean
this Bishop is never getting out of here
so one of other interesting things is
that okay the Queen is I engage seven
Knight to g5 would really force a black
to weaken his position so h6 definitely
strongest and Leela confirmed it you
know on the spot it's okay
a4 and not along a3 to be a target
anymore and here we have Knight to e7 by
Caruana Knight to e5 by Carlsen and
Bishop to d6 now and here Carson was a
very much low on time and well not not
very much but he did spindle like at
half an hour for those two moves and he
he couldn't really find a way how to
push for any advantage with the white
pieces which is kind of important you
know World Chess Championship match so
here if you try something like Bishop to
g3 this night from e7 is coming to a5
your Bishop is now under attack there's
not not much to be happy about here
instead of this Bishop to g3 you could
try something like Knight to d3 to try
and exchange the dark square bishop but
then after captures captures you have
this pawn captures on c4 and then after
rook captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures we basically trade down into
this exact same material position where
both players have a light square Bishop
to Knights Queens but one thing you do
realize is that Corona has two point
islands there are two connected points
on the Queen side whereas Carlson has
two isolated pawns a pawn and C pawn and
of course this pawns pawn mass on the
Kings side but those are three pointer
islands which basically
caranas pawn structure being more intact
makes it much more easier to play and
and of course it is better so nothing to
begin here and here Carlson trying to
gain at least some advantage he decided
after some 16 minutes the pawn captures
on d5 a very interesting idea because
now after Knight captures on d5 there is
a double attack against the c3 pawn and
here Carlson also spent some 11 minutes
to play Bishop to f3 Bishop to f3 is a
very nice move also a thing to consider
maybe c4 not allowing this one to stay a
target and forcing this night away from
here but then again it's a pretty force
variation night captors on c4 pawn
captors on f4 Bishop captures on e5 rook
captures on the 8 with Czech Queen
captures pawn captures on e5 and now
Bishop to d7 and now you would see that
again White's isolated point would be
will be a weakness there will be an
attack against the de-spawn the Queen
will be able to come to a5 to help out
with the attack against the weak Queen
side pawns and after something like for
example Bishop to f3 black will defend
his b7 pawn which is OK for now a bit of
a weakness but after white continues
attacking it to look to be one which
will oppose causing strong light square
Bishop captures captures and again we'll
have this trade at the down position
where again black would have a better
pawn structure and at some point you
will play b6 and white will not be able
to take advantage of anything here so
like we said after Knight captures on d5
Bishop to f3 and here Knight captures on
f4 and corona did spend some time on
this Knight captures on f4 because here
if he decided to go for something like
Queen captures on c3 then we have a
really exciting variation which cross
and also saw as he spent a lot of time
calculating if Queen captures Knight
captures and now black did win a pawn
but only temporarily because now you
have Knight captures on f7 a very
exciting move or now of course if black
captures here white will capture the
rook here and of course a lot of a lot
of attacks have opened up here but the
idea is after King captures on f7 now
you get simple rook captures rook
captures Bishop captures and now again
it's it's a position where you would
have this bishop pair against a knight
and the bishop and rooks and although
okay you can capture on a4 but the
bishop there will be it will be
sufficient to compensate for the loss of
a pawn and whites intact phone structure
on the King side will be much better
than blacks shattered
King side
so this was the idea but Corona doesn't
think that this is good for him after
this Bishop to have three he decides to
go knife captures on f-4e captors on i-4
and now Bishop captures on e5 who have
rook captures Queen captures and pawn
captures on e5 a very similar position
to what we already discussed Queen to c7
and now rook to be one starting to pile
up on that b7 pawn here we have rook to
b8 if you play something like Queen
captures on e5 this is somewhat of a
poisoned pawn because of Queen to d3
going after Queen to d8 you can't
develop the bishop so the rope would
guard the last rank one of the problems
would black is although he's hanging on
and it's a pretty equal positioning
material he's a bit more passive so
after the Queen goes back to guard the
d8 corner comes a rook to d1 and now it
would be very very uncomfortable for
black how do you prevent Queen to d8
black would have to play something like
f5 to create some breathing space for
his King and yeah you know you don't
want to allow white so much activity so
after Luke to be one rook to b8 was
played keeping an eye on that b7 pawn
queen to d3 and now comes the Bishop to
d7 attacking da for pawn if you decided
to capture on e5 now for example Queen
captures on in 5 then you get Queen to
d8 check King moves and now Queen to e7
again most likely black will be able to
hold this but now the f7 point is a weak
there is a triple attack against the b7
pawn again you give white a whole lot of
activity there are back ranked
weaknesses for white so white will have
to waste a move with h3 at some point
but still you know you don't want to
allow your opponent any activity ever so
after Queen to b3
Bishop to d7 a nice developing move also
comes with an attack against the f4 pawn
and here comes a 5 now a 5 is playable
because the Queen cannot capture it as
the bishop on d7 would be would be very
weak Bishop to c6 we have Queen to d6
offering a queen trade and Caruana
you know that goes for it Queen captures
pawn captures Bishop captures on f3 pawn
captures on f3 and now comes King f8
karana will now
start babbling his King into the game
block the pawn and so on
c4 a very nice move if you try a6
immediately then b6 will be super fine
for black black the black rook will now
be able to move there will be no more
upon weakness than b7 so instead first
Carson prepares a c4 we have King to e8
Corona keeps on bringing his kingdoms of
the game a six now b6 and now comes c5
this was Carlson's plan simply going for
that b6 point as the rookin b8 is
undefended Kings to d7 and now comes
pawn captures on b6 pawn captures and b6
and now a7 forcing the rook to go to
eight so you can capture the b6 pawn
rook to e8 row capture son b6 route
characters on a 7 and now came to g3
Khurana is not up upon here but of
course at some point he will capture the
d6 pawn he will simply move this pawn
move the King here plays they put the
room behind upon and then capture it the
white king is simply too far away to
come and help out and such a move was
played with an e5 route to before and
now f5 look back to be 6 and now King
does come to see 6 now like we've
mentioned the rook is coming here you
will capture the pawn and then you will
have a 4 to 3 advantage which will most
likely be winning so constant decides to
give up on with check its the 17
captures and now rook attacks the pawn
similarly constant was up upon yesterday
and he was trying to push for a win over
being up upon advantage you know rock n
game here the situation is opposite its
callsign actually who's down upon in a
rock n game and he will now has have to
try and defend his position King to e6
and now comes King b6 check King f7 King
the b5 again rook to be fine attacking
the pawn king defends the pawn rook to
b6 check again King g5 and now cousin
attacks the pawn on e5 once again King
defends it on f4 and rook to be four
check we have E for pawn captures pawn
captures and now h3 taking away the g4
square form the black King
we have rope to a five by Corona and now
comes a roof to b7 attacking the g7 pawn
rook the g5 check King moves to f1 and
now comes a rook to g6 rook to be for
not allowing black to push this pawn any
time rope the g5 and now comes rock back
to b7 rook to g6 rope the before and it
was actually in this position on move 49
that the players agreed to a draw as no
no more progress can be made here for
black even though he's up upon one thing
you might try is well if he tried
something like king king of three then
white would simply not allow you to stay
there rugby three check and now after
King a for he would again go look to
before and we would have this exact same
position on the other hand if you try
something like rook to e6 to prepare
King f3 and only then push III white
will simply kick you back with King to
g2 the King is no longer allowed on f3
and if there are any new players here we
might also check a variation what
happens if black simply starts pushing
all of his King side pawns exchanges
let's say g5 and let's say white is
simply repeating move the waiting to see
what black does let's say h5 g for now
white will simply capture and now if
King captures you will have this very
unfortunate f3
this comes with check the e pawn is
pinned King has to move captures
captures captures and after King
captures this will be a draw as there
will be no way no way for black to get
the white king away from the Queen Queen
Square and of course it will end in a
stalemate and on the other hand after H
captors on g4 if you don't capture what
it can give you capture with the H pawn
it doesn't really change anything still
white will move and now after g3 or any
thing any move you try to break through
this a white will again play this f3
move and still d4 pawn is pinned there
is nothing to do here captures captures
captures captures captures it's a draw
by insufficient material so yeah after
loop to b4 and not such an exhaustive
exhausting game like yesterday I think
this game it was like a four hour game
or even three hours three hour and
something
three hour and something post a six plus
our first game so I guess I wouldn't say
the players were tired as I mean they
came really prepared and but it seemed
that Carlson Caruana just found a really
really really cool way of getting a
quick draw with the black pieces and
then he will look for his chance again
in Game three with the white pieces and
interestingly while talking to the
officer on that l40
little a a:0 developer he said that
Caruana was also using Lilla in during
his preparations so you know very
interesting and also very interesting
you know perhaps in 2020 we will see
maybe after you know self-learning AI is
become even more powerful how will this
affect human chess so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and once
again I I would like to thank all of you
who have waited for my video you are in
a truly an excellent subscriber
although feel free to check out all of
the other videos as well as I'm sure
there you will learn even more and you
know there is a lot of vast knowledge to
be to be gathered here I would also like
to thank even your over Gareth Davies
you get right in there you know right in
there
Krister sorry crystal icon and Robert
Young quest for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous video so you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
most likely with Game three but perhaps
we will have an interesting game in
between also I'm flying back to Croatia
tomorrow morning so the maybe not next
but then you will again have my usual
setting and not this hotel room thank
you all and I will see you soon